So, in this lesson, we've learned many different things about what personality
is, what it's dimensions are, how we measure it. What are the causes of
personality, and even whether animals have personality. So, for instance, we've
seen that personality is uniquely behaving in a similar way over time and in
many different situations. So, the basic dimensions of personality are the so
called big five or ocean dimensions. So, openness, conscientiousness,
extraversion, agreeableness, and neuroticism. We've also seen how personality
is measured both qualitatively and quantitatively. Qualitatively, we measure
personality through interviews and ink box. And quantitatively we measure it
through self report and behavioral observations. We've also seen how
personality and the causes of personality can be studied through twin adoption
studies. So, to see how genes and environment play a role in our personalities.
And then finally, we have seen how animals, nonhuman animals, share some
personality traits common with humans. So, for instance, extroversion and
neuroticism.